hello my name is Angela Loma Kang
welcome to 3abn today Bible q a
I know you're going to be blessed by
this program I am every time we open the
word of God and you know my husband and
I at home we love reading the word of
God and we take turns reading it he'll
do seven say if it's maybe 21 verses
he'll do seven I'll do seven and we've
just really dig into the word and it's
so confident to know that this word is
our light and our lamp to our path
well before we go into the program I
want to thank you for your prayers and
your financial support of this program
and if you want here's the program
format all answers are three minutes
long with one answer be in four minutes
and so let's go right into our guess and
so I would like to first introduce right
across from me is my husband John Loma
Kang welcome honey always good to have
you in that seat asking the questions I
always said I could never host because
I'll be dying to answer the question
you know I'd like to be a volcano
sitting here one day erupt yeah but it's
good to be able to answer God's word
according to his leading and His holy
spirit amen good to see you honey amen
thank you James Rafferty thank you for
being here once again you're home aren't
you every time you're here you are this
is home good to be here Angie looking
forward to the questions and the answers
amen and a wonderful Shelley Quinn oh I
just want to thank everybody for sending
in your questions because this is what
this gives us the reason to do this
program and we love doing it so thank
you yes all right well I'd like to start
with a word of prayer so matter of fact
I'd like to Shelley would you please
absolutely Heavenly Father we come in
the name of Jesus and we thank you for
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ we
thank you for your Holy Spirit and how
we thank you for your word you didn't
leave us as orphans send your Holy
Spirit now to give us ears to hear and a
heart to practice what your word says
Lord please bless all the viewers bless
the crew and bless this time we spend
together in Jesus name amen amen thank
you now if you'd like to get in touch
with us you and you have a question you
can text us by going to by texting at
618-228-3975 or you can email us
at bible q a at
3abn.tv or you can Instagram us at 3abn
underscore official
all right well we're going to go
straight into our questions and the
first one is going to be you honey okay
we're going to start with a four minute
question so we're going to give you a
little time on this one
here it goes is there a difference
between the spirit of God and the Holy
Spirit this is from Joe in Florida and
they added the third person of the
godhead and thank you Joe for your
question you know this this topic has
been getting a lot of focus uh in recent
years what role does the Holy Spirit
play and people have been trying to
figure out his uh his participation in
the work of Salvation the work of
creation and human history but we find
that in my life as I study God's word uh
the issue is settled with me as far as
the work of the Holy Spirit uh can I
understand everything he does absolutely
not that shows that omnipotence and
omnipresence and omniscience is so much
more deep than a human is but I want to
make it clear that there are many
phrases the Bible uses to describe the
work of the third person of the godhead
so a very quick answer would be no and
you find a number of phrases I actually
have brought out about five of them to
show you how the Bible differs when it
comes to the phrase like the spirit of
God the Holy Spirit my spirit the spirit
of the Lord and even the comforted let's
go to Genesis 1 verse two you find one
of the first references the Bible says
the Earth was without form and void and
darkness was on the face of the deep and
the spirit of God was hovering over the
face of the waters and so you find there
that the Holy Spirit was very present in
the very beginning and to to even add
stronger support to that you find the
numbers 24 and verse 2. the Bible speaks
about Balaam you know who is a very
faithful Prophet to God but was was um
there was an appeal made to him to curse
the children of Israel and it says in
numbers 24 verse 2 and Balaam raised his
eyes and saw Israel encamped according
to their tribes and the spirit of God
Came Upon him when you look at those
phrases the spirit of God in Genesis 1 2
and numbers 24 2 same words the same
phrase in the Hebrew and now I find also
the Holy Spirit where David prayed in
Psalm 51 verse 11 do not cast me away
from your presence and do not take your
Holy Spirit from me you find out now we
go to the New Testament Matthew 1 verse
18. the phrase there in the Hebrew in
the Old Testament is Paramount to the
phrase in Matthew 1 verse 18 in the New
Testament where the Bible says now the
birth of Jesus was as follows
after his mother Mary was betrothed to
Joseph before they came together she was
found with child of the Holy Spirit
same terminology same person involved
the third person of the godhead and now
you have the addition because Jesus
breathed on his disciples and said
receive the holy spirit so what was the
purpose of the day of Pentecost to
receive the Holy Spirit and be imbued
with power and given the ability to
communicate in different languages which
the Holy Spirit enabled them to do acts
1 verse 8 but you shall receive power
when the Holy Spirit has come upon you
and you shall be witnesses to me in
Jerusalem and in all Judea and Samaria
and to the end of the Earth and so you
find the same phrase used there in
Matthew 1 18 and the Hebrew derivative
of that and
Psalm 51 verse 11 is the same person
being involved the third person of the
godhead you now find also the Holy
Spirit spoken of as my spirit Zechariah
4 and verse 6. so he answered and said
to me this is the word of the Lord to
zerubbabel not by might nor by power but
by my spirit says the Lord of hosts then
you find also in John Chapter 14 verse
26 you find the Holy Ghost there but the
Bible describes exactly who the Holy
Ghost is John 14 26 in the King James
version but the comforter which is the
Holy Ghost whom the father will send in
my name he shall teach you all things
and bring all things to your remembrance
whatsoever I have said unto you and so
you find the Bible uses a number of
phrases to talk about the Holy Spirit
but it means simply the third person of
the godhead amen that's right same
person of the godhead that was there
from the beginning from the very
beginning yes thank you for that okay
now James you have a very interesting
question a lot of people want to know
the answer to this one okay
this is from Tristan Michigan who are
the 24 Elders in heaven are they there
now
great question Trish from Michigan the
24 Elders are described in Revelation
chapter 4 and they're described there as
possessing those things which were
promised to the seven churches they have
white robes they are sitting on Thrones
they have crowns on their heads all of
these were promises given to those who
overcome in the seven churches so
Revelation 4 is picking up where the
seven churches leaves off it's throwing
us the throne room in heaven and it's
showing us there are four living
creatures there that God is there on the
throne but then it's showing us
something that has never been present in
the throne room before now what I mean
by that is Isaiah chapter 6 gives us a
picture of the throne room Daniel
chapter 7 gives us a picture of the
throne room Ezekiel chapter 1 gives us a
picture of the throne room and there you
have the living creatures and then you
have God in his glory on the throne but
you never see 24 Elders it's not until
we get to the Book of Revelation
post-resurrection of Jesus Christ who by
the way
when he was resurrected there was a
group of captains a multitude of people
that were resurrected with him after his
resurrection that is with an eternal
Resurrection just like his and they were
taken to heaven with Christ these these
this captive these people are the 24
Elders how do we know that well in the
Bible the word Elder is used over 175
times and it is never refers to anything
but a human being it doesn't refer to an
elder doesn't refer to any kind of
representative from that God has created
from any other world it always ever
refers to human beings and that's what
we want to do when we study the Bible
and especially the Book of Revelation we
want to look at the words that are used
we want to trace them through the
scriptures and see how they're used in
other Bible verses in other books in
other chapters and stories and then we
want to transpose that use Into the Book
of Revelation and see if it makes sense
now there can be several uses at times
but the word Elder is only ever used for
a human being in other words the 24
elders are in heaven in the throne room
as representatives of the redeemed and
we're told that in Revelation chapter
five because in Revelation chapter 5 as
you'll just look at these verses with me
in Revelation chapter 5 when he Jesus
Christ had taken the book verse 8
and the the four beasts and the 24
Elders fell down before the lamb every
one of them having Harps and golden
vials full of odors which are the
prayers of the Saints verse 9 and they
sang a new song saying Thou Art Worthy
to take the book to open the seals
thereof for thou was slain and has
redeemed us to God by thy blood out
every Kindred and tongue and people and
nation and verse 10 has made us Kings
and Priests
and we shall reign on the earth it's
made us unto our God Kings and Priests
and we shall reign on the earth you
might say well the Angels uh weren't
redeemed but the 24 Elders were and the
only way these verses can make sense is
to know that the worse there was a group
of people within those verses that were
redeemed for every nation Kinder tongue
and people and were made Kings and were
made priests we had more time we could
say this more but in Salvation symbols
of size we do a lot of study on this we
have an outline of study guide that you
can look at there that will give you
more information and more verses
beautiful answer isn't that thank you
beautiful and in a court you have what
12 jurors and there's usually an
alternate 12 that's 24. that's
interesting and then you have anyone
yeah yeah that's interesting so it's the
same court
system so to speak in heaven so that's
that's good to know thank you well said
okay Shelley you have a four minute
question so here we go this is from
Donna in Idaho
in Matthew 5 17 Jesus tells us that he
did not come to abolish the law but to
fulfill it
so what is Paul telling us in Ephesians
2 15. okay this Donna let me see if we
can do this in four minutes
in the context of Matthew 5 17 Jesus is
speaking not only of the Ten Commandment
moral law but he is also speaking of the
Civil statutes contained in Moses five
books and confirmed by the prophets
Ephesians 2 15.
Paul talks about the law contained in
ordinances that was unique to the Jewish
Nation that's the old Covenant the old
Covenant law was civil social and
ceremonial laws
Moses he records this from Exodus 20
verse 22 to Exodus 23 verse 33 he
records what God is giving to Israel as
a constitution in what he called the
book of the law that was the old
Covenant and it's interesting now the
Ten Commandments were at the heart of
that but Moses wrote the book of the
Covenant it ended up on the side of the
Ark and a temporary pocket on the side
of the Ark whereas God's ten
commandments ended up under The Mercy
Seat inside the ark
later that was considered in Deuteronomy
God added to these civil social and
ceremonial laws and it was called The
Book of the law so let me back up and
I'm going to take this in an interesting
way what did Jesus nail to the Cross
when when God wrote the book of the law
there were curses in this law and it
stood there as a witness against them
because God told Moses he said I know
these people are going to Rebel when
Jesus came to renew God's Everlasting
Covenant when he died what did he nailed
to the cross first Peter 2 24 Christ
bore our sins and his body and paid our
sin debt at the cross so his Precious
Blood blotted Out the certificate of
indebtedness that we have from our sins
Romans 6 6 is the second thing he nailed
to the cross Paul says our old man was
crucified with him that the body of sin
might be done away with that we should
no longer be slaves to sin but what else
was nailed to the cross the old Covenant
book of the law the Commandments
contained in ordinances that had to do
with drink offerings and food offerings
and annual sabbaths the feast day so
let's look quickly at this because my
time's going
Ephesians 2 we're going to begin with
verse 13. but now in Christ Jesus you
once who were far off have been brought
nearby the blood of Christ for he
himself is our peace who has made both
one talking about Jew and Gentile has
broken down the middle Wall of
Separation having abolished in his flesh
that would be on the cross the enmity
and then he explains the enmity that is
the law of Commandments contained in
ordinance is so as to create in himself
one new man from the two thus making
peace that he might reconcile them both
to God in one body through the cross now
when Christ ratified the New Covenant
the old Covenant was done away with he
nailed it to the cross the ceremonial
laws the sil even the Civil laws all of
those that served as the constitution of
Israel that old Covenant is gone and
dead Colossians 2 14 he says having
wiped out the handwriting of
requirements that was against us which
was contrary to us he's taken it out of
the way having nailed it to the Cross
having disarmed principalities and
Powers he made a public spectacle of
them triumphing over them in it so
that means therefore because of this let
no one judge you in food or drink he's
talking about food and drink offerings
or regarding a festival or a new moon or
Sabbath this is the annual Feast Sabbath
which were a shadow of things to come
but the substance is Christ amen wow
amen well said not enough time
wow so many are confused with the laws
they get the two laws mixed up the
ceremonial and the moral law but you
have a book what did you do the book is
is going to be called spotless the
Everlasting Covenant will have a whole
series on this probably that launches in
September all right amen looking forward
to that new book you're the Covenant
Queen
okay well said all right let's go on
well before we go on if you have a if
you just tuned in and you have a Bible
question and you'd like to send your
questions in
here is how you can do it text us by
going by texting us at
618-228-3975 or you can email us at
bibleqa at
3abn.tv or you can Instagram if you
enjoy Instagram you can go there by
going to at 3abn underscore official
okay all right here you go hon
here's this is an interesting question
wow this is from Gray in England in
England is great too isn't it sure this
is from Gray in England but it's also a
beautiful place because that's where I
was born
that's right okay do the dead dream
can you explain what this sleep is like
well I want to explain it biblically but
I cannot explain it experientially
praise God for that right very very
quick answer can the dead dream the
answer is no no so can I explain what
this sleep is like now this is such a
beautiful story you find in John chapter
11 Jesus addresses this directly Lazarus
Mary and Martha were good friends of
Christ he Jesus had no home of his own
but Mary and Martha and Lazarus were
good company good friends he was he
frequented their home and they knew him
very well so when this topic of the
death of Lazarus came to the Forefront
Martha and Mary knew exactly what the
Bible taught and uh they were concerned
that Jesus wasn't there in time to spare
their brother so let me just very
quickly because it's a very long topic
to answer the question why they cannot
dream Ecclesiastes 9 verse 5 and 6 for
the living know that they shall die but
the dead know not anything neither have
they any more a reward for the memory of
them is forgotten also their love their
hatred and their Envy is now perished
neither have they any more a portion
forever in anything done under the sun
why don't they dream Psalm 146 verse 4
his breath goeth forth he returned to
his Earth in that very day his thoughts
perish or the new king his plans perish
Psalm 115 verse 17 the dead do not
praise the Lord neither any that go down
into silence not up into activity down
into silence in Job 14 21 his sons come
to honor him like Memorial Day
he does not know it they are brought low
and he does not perceive it so there's
an unconsciousness and death but why
does the bible call it sleep well very
quickly it is sleep because there is a
resurrection you know there's a there's
a death that everybody who's living
could experience they're going to be
those alive when Jesus comes
but every one of us is subject to the
first death
and the Bible refers to that as sleep
John 11 verse 11 11 when Lazarus was
sick the Bible says then these things he
said after that he said to them our last
our friend Lazarus sleeps but I go that
I may wake him up and they thought that
Lazarus was going to do well because
he's getting rest whenever you sick you
need rest but Jesus said plainly in
verse 4 of John 11 then he said to them
plainly Lazarus is dead and then when he
met Martha along the way Jesus said to
her because she was really concerned he
said in verse 23 and 24 your brother
will rise again and Martha answered in
verse 24 I know that he will rise again
in the resurrection at the last day so
we're all sleeping until the
Resurrection The Righteous are sleeping
to the first resurrection the wicked are
sleeping till the second Resurrection
Revelation 20 verse 6 says this blessed
and holy is he who has part in the first
resurrection over such the second death
has no power what's the purpose of the
second Resurrection to come forth in the
white Throne judgment not to receive a
reward but to receive the punitive
punishment and that's why the Bible says
in Revelation 21 verse 8 but the
Cowardly the unbelieving the abominable
will all have their part on the Lake of
Fire which burns with Brimstone which is
the second death until the first or
second Resurrection everyone is sleeping
wow that's right and yeah we're sleeping
sometimes you have a dreamless sleep too
though but this death is different
though that's right it's totally
different you don't you don't dream at
all thank you for that okay let's go on
all right James Rafferty this is your
four minute question okay okay this is
from Lizzy in New Zealand
could you explain the
1290 slash 1333 prophecy of Daniel 12.
1290 and 1335 prophecy of Daniel 12
Lizzy they are
difficult but if we understand a
principle and that is that in the Book
of Daniel there's a little horn power
that is attacking God's Everlasting
Covenant in Daniel chapter 7 this little
horn power attacks the law of God
because that is a vital part of the New
Covenant promise in Hebrews chapter 8
and chapter 10. and in Daniel chapter 8
the little horn attacks the sanctuary of
God because that is also a vital part of
the New Covenant promise where God says
I'm going to forgive their sins and
iniquities and remember them no more so
the little horn is a religious political
power a religio political power and it
it comes to its strength it comes to its
own in the Middle Ages now there are two
dates that are connected to this little
horn power the first date is 5 38 when
it's civil strength is Consolidated and
that takes us 260 years to 1798 we don't
have time to talk about the details here
but there's another part of this power
the religious part and that that power
is Consolidated in 508 before the Civil
power is Consolidated the religious
power is Consolidated in other words it
becomes a religious power before it
becomes a civil power
and that date 508 is will we line up the
1290 and the 1335. the 1290 begins with
a consolidation of this religion
religious power that seeks to attack
Christ's Sanctuary the Heavenly
sanctuary and cast it to the Earth not
literally because that Sanctuary can't
be cast to the Earth literally but by
counterfeit in other words this power is
seeking to counterfeit the work and
Ministry of Christ in the Heavenly
Sanctuary it's seemingly set up a
counterfeit Sanctuary on this Earth with
a counterfeit priesthood accountant
mediation that replaces the mediation
the priesthood of Jesus Christ and
that's exactly what happened as this
power exerted its religious muscles
beginning in 508 it continued on for
over
1290 years those are prophetic days or
literal years until we get to 1798 where
the 538 and the 1290 meet this power
receives or is inflicted with a deadly
wound but Daniel chapter 12 indicates a
blessing on those who come to the 1335.
now how does that connect with the 1290
well it wasn't until
1843 which is 508 plus 1335 1843 that a
group of people called the millerites
went through a bitter disappointment now
This Bitter disappointment began with a
date they set for the cleansing of the
sanctuary they believed that the
sanctuary to be cleansed was this earth
and the date was based on the 2300 day
prophecy including the 1290 and the
1335. they were wrong on the sanctuary
and understanding what the sanctuary was
but they were correct on the timeline
the sanctuary to be cleansed was not the
Earth by the second coming of Jesus and
destroying the Wicked with with fire but
it was the sanctuary in heaven the
mediation of Christ in heaven and this
truth was Unearthed after the first and
second disappointment 1843 1844 the
millerites who held on to their faith
believing in this timeline eventually
saw the sanctuary truth that was the
blessing they received to see the
sanctuary uncovered the sanctuary that
was to be cleansed at the end of the
2300-day prophecy and so these two time
prophecies indicate the power of little
horn consolidating its strength to
attack the New Covenant by attacking the
law in Daniel 7 attacking the sanctuary
in Daniel chapter 8 and that truth being
obscured for the 1260 the 1290 to 1335
until finally it was revealed through
that disappointment in 1843 and 1844 and
today me coming from a Roman Catholic
background realized that there's only
one mediator between man and God the man
Christ Jesus First Timothy chapter 2
verse 5 that we have a Heavenly
Sanctuary a Heavenly mediator and the
counterfeit has been set aside at least
in my heart and hopefully in yours
breath James yeah he's like how do you
answer that in four minutes that was
good four minutes he did a wonderful job
answering that question praise God all
right here we go Shelley
this is from Shirley in Wyoming here we
go what is the meaning of Revelation 1
verse 4. the seven spirits Before the
Throne oh it's surely there's a lot of
people who ask this question Revelation
1 verse 4 John to the seven churches
which are in Asia he says grace to you
in peace from him who is who was and who
is to come and from the seven spirits
who are before his throne in biblical
symbolism seven is the number of
completion or Perfection and the
reference here is to the seven-fold
Ministry of the Holy Spirit let's go to
Isaiah 11 and verse 2 in Isaiah 11 and
verse 2 we see this Sevenfold Ministry
of the Holy Spirit and it says the
spirit of the Lord that's the first
Ministry shall rest upon it the spirit
of wisdom
understanding the spirit of counsel the
spirit of Might the spirit of knowledge
and of the fear of the Lord now
Zachariah 4 1-6
it shows two olive trees in this
prophecy and these two trees these olive
trees we're going to see that the holy
spirit is simple is symbolized here oil
is a symbol of the holy spirit so
Zachariah I'm going to read verses 5 and
6. the angel who talked with me answered
and said to me do you not know what
these are these olive trees and I said
no my Lord so he answered and said to me
this is the word of the Lord to
subrubbabel not by my nor by power but
by my spirit says the Lord in the
sanctuary there was
the sanctuary in the Old Testament there
was a seven branched Candlestick that
had multiple almond shaped bowls and
these Bowls the Candlestick itself was
to represent Jesus he said I am the
light of the world it was the only light
in the sanctuary but what were in these
bowls was the purest hand-pressed Olive
or olive oil and this was the fuel
source well in biblical symbolism still
we're talking oil is the holy spirit oil
is the Sevenfold Ministry of God that
Perfection and he is
our fuel source
amen amen I like that that's right he is
that's right the oil
thank you Shelly beautiful well said and
Sanctuary language again isn't it
okay now
John we have an interesting question and
it's pretty deep so here goes
I this is from Rosa I have been seeing
where the Euphrates River has dried up
the Book of Revelation 9 verse 14 and 16
verse 12 says
when it's dried up demons will be
released is it safe to say the river is
dried up and we are at the point of
waiting for one third of mankind to be
killed
well thank you so much for Rosa for this
question this is another one of those
let's try to press it in together
I understand the river Euphrates first
first and foremost the river Euphrates
was the river that supplied water that
surrounded the Antiquated City or the
Babylonian city of antiquity as long as
there was water in that moat the city
was impregnable uh it was the sustaining
power of that Babylonian City you find
conversely Revelation talks about that
in Revelation chapter 16 verse 12 then
the sixth Angel poured out his bowl on
the great river Euphrates and its Waters
were dried up so that the way of the
kings of the East might be prepared so
if you look at how ancient Babylon fell
it fell when its Waters were prevented
from supplying the protection that the
Antiquated City needed and they were
attacked from beneath and the city was
brought to its knees and you read that
in the story of Daniel chapter 5 when
Nebuchadnezzar's grandson beltashaza was
having a a drunken party and the Bible
says he saw a hand without a hand
without an arm saying your kingdom has
been divided and given to the mees and
the Persians that city was brought down
but now the Bible talks about spiritual
Babylon in Revelation chapter 16 and
Revelation chapter 9 we find these two
terminologies there what's the water
what does the water represent when you
go to Revelation chapter 17 we talk
about the great Harlot that sits on the
waters Revelation 17 verse 1 then one of
the Seven Angels who had seven bolds
came and talked with me saying come I
will show you the Judgment of the great
Harlot who sits on many Waters now watch
this the support system of Babylon
symbolically then he said to me the
waters which you saw where the Harlot
sits our people multitudes Nations and
tongues and so the waters that supported
ancient Babylon represent the people
that support symbolic Babylon today this
system of religious and political
confusion that will one day embrace the
entire world largely spiritually corrupt
but the Bible talks about what's going
to happen to the city so the waters
there are summarizing a support system
below Revelation 18 verse 9 and 11. how
are the judgments going to come upon
symbolic Babylon here it is
so rather than waiting for demons to be
released to kill a third of mankind
because some people have been looking at
the waters in the in the Middle East
saying it's drying up like the water
shortages and this means that there's
going to be some demonic attack the way
that Babylon symbolically is going to be
attacked is by the very people that
supported it here's Revelation 18 verse
9 to 11. the kings of the earth who
committed fornication and lived
luxuriously with her will weep and
lament for her when they see the smoke
of her burning standing at a distance
for fear for torment saying at last alas
that great City Babylon that Mighty City
for in one hour your judgment has come
and the merchants of the earth will weep
and mourn over her for No One buys her
merchandise any longer the very people
that were deceived by that system will
be the very ones that bring judgment on
that system before God terminates it
permanently so no we're not waiting for
demons to attack we are waiting for God
Babylon has fallen has fallen he'll call
his people out and then he'll bring that
system to its knees amen he'll say what
come out of her come out of her my
people be not partakers his people are
out there right exactly yeah it's
already under demonic influence clearly
it's become the habitation of every
fouled spirit in the cage of unclean and
hated every unclean and hateful bird so
it's already under demonic control God's
come out before the bride and the
bridegroom are no longer hurt in her
it's amazing how Satan puts those
counterfeits out there oh yeah yeah so
people look at my literal stuff when
it's in that symbolic message yes amen
thank you thank you well said all right
okay James this is from Gene in Virginia
when we stand before the Judgment seat
of Christ will it be just for us and him
only or will everyone be there together
good question what a good question Gene
you know you always wonder about that
because you think
a bunch of people going to see when I
when I'm judged are they going to see
all of my record and everything that I
did and the answer is absolutely not
amen it's so beautiful to think about
how God has set up the Plan of Salvation
and we're just going to look at a couple
of verses here in first Timothy chapter
5. now these verses are challenging but
they're very powerful they're very
beautiful verses that describe how this
process takes place because believe it
or not if you're a believer in Jesus
Christ you actually don't stand in front
of the Judgment seat of Christ literally
in your physical body with the standard
of the law compared to your actions and
Christ their mediating for you this old
takes place right now in a spiritual
context right so we are by faith
Ephesians says sitting in Heavenly
places in Christ Jesus and by faith
our lives have been investigated that's
why we say search me oh God I know my
heart try me and know my thoughts and
see if there be any wicked way in me and
Lead Me in the way Everlasting that word
Try by the way in Psalm 139 23-24 means
to investigate in the in the Hebrew
language so the investigative judgment
is what's being talked about there and
all through the Bible so in first
Timothy Chapter 5 beginning with verse 4
it says 24 it says now some men's sins
are open beforehand going to judgment
and some men they follow after
so if you're a Believer your sins go
beforehand a judgment amen while you're
on this Earth while you're living in
breathe that's why there are times when
you feel overwhelmed with guilt
overwhelmed with the weight of your
unchrist likeness okay your failures
well that's an opportunity for you to
send your sins beforehand to judgment to
give your sins to Jesus if we confess
our sins he's faithful and Justified
give us our sins and to cleanse us from
all unrighteousness and you know what
he's going to do after that
he's going to blot out those sins so
that nobody ever sees them and we're
told that in Acts chapter 3 verses 18
through 21 but let's just stick here for
a little bit longer now because there's
another verse verse 25 that parallels
verse 24 it says the same thing as verse
24 but it gives us a completely
different insight to this whole process
I'm going to read 24 again some men's
sins are open beforehand going to
judgment and some men they follow after
if you're a Believer your sins go
beforehand if you're not a Believer they
follow after and everyone's going to see
them likewise verse 25 also the good
works of Summer manifest beforehand and
they that are otherwise cannot be hid
now that means if you're a Believer and
your sins go beforehand God takes those
sins he gives you his spirit and you
manifest good works in your life that's
what happens to a Believer they live a
Godly life of Good Works amen and if you
don't live a Godly life of good works
the if you have bad Works your works are
not going to be those that are otherwise
those that are not good cannot be hidden
the bad Works can't be hidden unless
they go beforehand to the Judgment so
God wants to blot out your sins he
doesn't want anyone to see them and no
one will see them if you send the
beforehand to judgment by confessing
them to Jesus Christ and letting him
take care of those sins and cleanse you
from all unrighteousness
yeah and he casts them into the depths
of the sea and put out an old fishing
sign
I'm so glad he does that amen no fishing
period yeah what a mighty God we serve
he's so forgiving and loving oh boy okay
Shelly let's go to you beautiful I love
Bible q a
in this is Cheryl in Illinois she sent a
text in in referencing John 4
23-24 would you please elaborate on what
worshiping in spirit and truth is
Cheryl thank you for this question I'm
going to read John 4 23 and 24. Jesus is
speaking and he says to the woman at the
well but the hour is coming and now is
when the true worshipers will worship
the father in spirit and Truth for the
father is seeking such to worship him
God is spirit and those who worship Him
must Worship in spirit and Truth God is
Spirit capitalists
but we worship in spirit little less and
Truth see once the Messiah arrived it no
longer mattered where they worshiped but
how they worshiped
when Jesus Christ was here now we are no
longer required to do rituals and
pilgrimages and travel you know for the
feast days to Jerusalem and all that to
Worship in spirit is referring to our
human spirit this is talking about
worshiping
inwardly from our heart this is to
worship
with sincere
reverence to adore him to Worship in
spirit and in truth we must Worship in a
way that is revealed in scripture
applying the truth to our hearts it's
and I'm going to tell you something
obedience motivated by love is the
highest expression of worship that there
is let me read three quick scriptures
Micah 6 8 Amplified he has showed you o
man what is good and what does the Lord
require of you but to do justly
to walk to show loving kindness and
mercy and to humble yourself and walk
humbly be with your God we are to depend
on God and His Plan of Salvation
Deuteronomy 10 12. this is what Moses
told to the Israelites now Israel this
is the second generation standing at the
edge of promise what does the Lord your
God require of you
but reverently to fear the lord your God
re
reverence him that is here's he's
explaining what fears to walk in all his
ways and to love him and to serve your
God with all of your mind and heart and
with your entire being so we worship in
truth and in spirit from deep within us
but I do want to point out a scripture
in Philippians 3 3. it's Paul says we
Christians are the true circumcision who
Worship in spirit
and by the spirit of God and exult and
glory and pride ourselves in Jesus
Christ and we put no confidence on our
flesh so Worship in spirit is from the
depths of our heart
relying on the truth as revealed to us
by the holy spirit amen in first Samuel
15 22 obedience is better than sacrifice
amen amen okay thank you Shelly
beautiful
if you have a question you'd like to
send in you can send your questions in
right now or you can send it in later
you can text it to us at
618-228-3975 or you can email us at
bible QA
3abn.tv or you can Instagram us at 3abn
underscore official okay all right
here's your last question John this is
an interesting one it's short and to the
point this is from Marion Oregon can you
please explain Proverbs 22 verse 5. sure
the Bible says in Proverbs 22 verse 5
Mary thorns and sneers are in the way of
the perverse he who guards his soul will
be far from them simply put the life
that has lived in opposition to the
Lord's will will be injured by the
thorns and snares of sin you find Psalm
91 verse 3 surely he shall deliver you
from the sneers of the Fowler that is
what happens to the righteous one we are
delivered from the the snares of the
enemy you also find in Psalm 38 verse 12
those also who seek my life lay snares
for me the enemy puts out snares to try
to to try to trip up the people of God
but God protects those who trust in him
you find also in first Timothy 6 verse 9
but those who desire to be rich fall
into temptation and snare and a snare
once again all of these are attempts to
pull the people of God away from doing
the will of God so simply put if we make
decisions to stay away from those things
that injure us and cause us to be the
pray of the devil we are guarding our
soul from the snares proverbs 4 verse 14
do not enter the path of the wicked and
do not walk in the way of evil
wow yeah that's right to the point to
the point don't even do it right do it
no no amen thank you okay okay James
this is an interesting question this is
from Rollins in Zambia
in judges 11
37-28 we find the word bewail more
specifically in verse 38 which says and
she went with her Companions and
bewailed her virginity upon the
mountains what does it mean did she
commit fornication or what happened hmm
good question Rollins this is a
difficult
story in a sense and when you look at
this story you realize that it centers
around a man who is faithful to God and
God gave him a great Victory and he made
a vow to God that whatever would come
out of his door when he went back to his
home he would make that a burnt offering
to God well what came out of his door we
went home when he went home was his
daughter and so that's where you pick up
the story you ask the question you know
what does it mean that she was bewailing
her virginity on the mountains and then
you mentioned well did she commit
fornication no no she didn't commit
fornication she was bewailing her
virginity because God excuse me his her
father had said that she was going to be
a sacrifice to God and she realized that
what that meant was what that implied
was that she was never going to be
married she was never going to have
children she was never going to have her
own life she was going to be dedicated
to the Lord now some people suggest that
it was a burned offering that God was
actually going to sacrifice her as a
burnt offer but
when you look at the phrase burnt
offering in judges 11 and verse 31
you're going to find that even though
that is usually translated burnt
offering there are two exceptions and
I'm going to say likely three exceptions
including this one where that isn't
actually translated as a burnt offering
and it doesn't fit you can't translate
that phrase as a burnt offering in First
Kings chapter 10 verse 5 and in Ezekiel
chapter 40 verse 26 and neither can you
do it here in Judges chapter 11. now
several important points can be learned
from this one is that there may be
uh a difficulty in US
following through the vows we make to
God and in this case there was no
difficulty he promised God he made the
vow to God and he was going to follow
through with this vow and our vows to
God should not be done as a purchase of
favor to God of some way of of claiming
his Merit it's simply a humble
recognition of God's blessing in God's
favor on us but we need to be
very careful when we make vows this was
about that her father made and he
probably thought an animal was going to
come out to greet him you know I would
have thought maybe his you know dog
course they may have had family dogs
like we do today would be the first one
out the door but it was his daughter we
need to be careful what kind of vows we
make to the Lord and then there's a
similar some a solemnness about our vows
to God that we performed them and that
those vows should be lawful vows and not
difficult vows and there's again some
people that say that jephthah you know
in performing his vows probably gave his
daughters a burnt offering that is not
implied in the story you can put that
into the story but it's not there
because he would be violating the law of
God to do that God did not require him
to make a vow that would cause him to
transgress his law amen but every and we
see that in the context of story that uh
the children are the daughters of Israel
would go up and lament her virginity and
of course that implies with her in the
context of the story I'm out of time
right now but anyway that's that's
that's as good as we can get as far as
the answer goes I hope that's right
shall not kill you that's good thank you
thank you James wow we answered that
very well okay Shelly this is an
interesting question this is from James
in Delaware
can you help me understand the fate of
Jew s of Judas
Christ came to Earth to be slain for us
then why is Judas guilty is it that
Christ could have given his life some
other way in order to save us and did
not have to be betrayed and killed
could he have just died or offered
himself that's Jesus to the priest to be
slain and it would have accomplished the
same purpose okay
let me try to answer this in two parts
maybe yeah if we have time
first of all I have to tell you that
Judas was not predestined
to
betray the Lord
Judas wasn't born to betray the Lord God
by omniscience Knew What Judas would do
but Judas walked for three and a half
years he walked with the Lord he saw the
Miracles he saw the things that he did
and Judas his his character his greedy
betraying thievery he never was
influenced by Jesus so
Judas chose his own lot in life by Free
Will and let me prove this to you the
Last Supper
I'm going to be it's in all the gospels
but I'm going to paraphrase John 13
1-10.
Jesus trying to reach Judas
and what we see is that God had Let
Jesus know that Judas was the one who
was had was turning him over to the
religious leaders and you know we know
that Jesus got up from the table and he
humbled himself to wash the feet this
was a
task that was relegated to the lowest of
the serpents but Jesus even washed Judas
speak think about this the savior is
washing the feet of someone he knows has
already betrayed him yes we know Ezekiel
33 11 God does not want anyone to die
he's asking them to turn First Timothy 2
4 God does not want anyone to die he
wants all men to repent and be saved
second Peter 3 9 we see the same thing
so
God never changes and he does all that's
within his power to save us by his love
so what did he do he's washing his feet
Christ comments at the Last Supper
seemed to be a veiled pleading to Judas
it's interesting because it was an
invitation to Judas to turn around he
called out his betrayer but not by name
he proclaimed that not all of his
disciples were clean and guess what
they're all chicken themselves oh but
Judas and he does the strongest warning
in Matthew's account it's in Matthew 26
24 he says the son of man indeed goes
just as it is written of him but woe to
the Man by whom the son of man is
betrayed it would have been good for
that man if he had not been born he
gives him a choice morsel of bread which
was an honor of a special guest
Judas and Jesus knew he was identifying
his betrayer the other disciples were
clueless so what happens
Jesus is pleading with him
Judas sat there at the table he rejected
the Lord and the Bible says that Satan
entered him right there at the table he
got up and walked out into the night air
away from the only person that could
save him wow so Judas
had ample opportunity to repeat it he
could have repented the Lord we're
reading about it yeah
he couldn't repented but Jesus had to
die because it had he had to become a
human being take on our flesh and live a
perfect life because it had to be a
human
representative who died for us wow
well said are you enjoying this program
like I am I am enjoying it I'm loving
the word of God I'm always learning
something new and these wonderful people
here lady and gentlemen has done a
wonderful job in sharing the word of God
with you and with me well we're gonna go
take a break we're going to give you
some information on how you can get in
touch with us and send your questions in
to us we will be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3ab in Bible q a for answers from
God's word
welcome back any closing thoughts from
our panel well I don't know everybody's
looking at me so I guess I'll just dive
in there go first okay well you know the
topic on sleep you know somebody talked
about uh what does the bible mean when
it says sleep yeah I want to make
there's a passage I wanted to include
which is so vitally important first
Thessalonians 4 verse 13 where the Bible
continually but this is the one that I
want to make very clear but I do not
want you to be ignorant Brethren
concerning those who are asleep unless
you sorrow as others who have no hope
when you die you are in a condition of
sleep like when you go to bed tonight
you don't know what happens until you
wake up in the morning when our
Consciousness is ceased at death we
don't know anything until the
Resurrection Day so the Bible completely
Old Testament and New Testament
continues to think of and teach death as
a sleep if I die before the Lord comes I
want to be in the first resurrection
amen amen okay yeah just come concerning
the story of jephthah in Judges chapter
11. you know there are passages in the
Bible that are difficult even for
Scholars they struggle with them but
what God has made plain is the Plan of
Salvation and we don't need to be
troubled about the fact that God loves
us and that we have salvation in Jesus
Christ so let's make sure we focus on
that right amen and amen Worship in
spirit and Truth God wants us to worship
with all of our heart by the scriptures
and I don't believe we can worship
without the holy spirit because without
being led by him we're not even a child
of God Amen thank you panel you all did
a wonderful job and I'm going to share a
scripture with you in closing Hebrews 4
12 for the word of God is living and
powerful and sharpened in any to its
sword Pierce into the division of Soul
and Spirit and the joints and Marrow and
is a discerner of thoughts and the
intent of the heart thank you for
joining us
birthday
[Music]